so ollie before we get into the new
album and new music i know you uh said
on social media that you got covets i
just wanna know how you're feeling
oh i'm i'm doing much better thank you i
didn't have it badly at all thankfully
so
yeah so yeah so it was really mild thank
you but um and now it was just annoying
because i tested positive like the full
times i had to do the full isolation
period so by by day seven i was just
going a bit out of my mind but i'm
feeling much better thanks so yeah all
good
yeah exactly right of course
well just in time to talk about this new
album night call so good um but we have
to talk about the cover because you're a
beautiful merman thank you so much yes
how did that idea come about
okay so i i i really love mermaids
basically like
me too
what's not to love
and i wanted to be a mermaid in a video
actually like i wanted to be my own kind
of like mermaid merman sensation but
it's cost a lot of money and i just
didn't really have the budget so i was
like okay but we still want this mermaid
character and and um actually like they
kind of became a muse for the album like
just i love the whole story behind you
know like she's she's alone on the rocks
kind of like
singing her beautiful voice and she
lures the sailors to their death and i
was like that's
i relate to her and
i just found out yeah this is not the
disney version
um so long story short i just like
wanted an excuse to dress up as a
mermaid
well it was and was it fun because you
look so good
thank you
do you know what
i actually didn't it wasn't a real tale
like i didn't have the tail on i know i
know
it's really sad it's a painted tail but
this is the thing i want to get real
tale i'm going to get a tail made so i
can do it and somehow but yeah perfect
i look forward to this then um you know
one of the songs that's so catchy that
so many of your fans are connecting with
this sweet talker it's so good but even
better is the music video how much fun
did you have working with that and
creating that
so much fun i
you know like every time we make a music
video i just want to like be as
ambitious as possible you know and i had
this idea to
make it like a fairy tale match up and
um i work with this really great
director called sofia ray and she like
had so many great ideas like this whole
candy kingdom you know playing off of
the whole sweet talker theme so it was
just really fun to go to make and yeah
go watch it i slay a beast i do tango
it all it's all it all goes on and you
eat a lot of cake
that was like
it was a hot day at work
was that fun like that was my favorite
scene was i mean don't get me wrong it
was fun watching with the sword but i
also just love that room of cakes
it was so good like they just honestly
we shot this shot that scene in a hotel
in um
in bulgaria
oh my gosh oh wow
that was that was crazy like i almost
forgot um and we
and um it was literally like they built
it just like in
one of the rooms like in the hotel they
just built this cake room like the whole
the whole three walls and all the cakes
like it was amazing it was just so it
was just they did such a good job i
loved it it was amazing
yeah well speaking of really awesome
music videos your music video for crave
has your uh it's a sin co-stars
appearing in it as well what was that
experience how special was that
i'm just like so grateful because i
really like i wrote them all in to do it
i was like please please please they all
said yes they were all like really they
were just so amazing because um i it was
nathaniel who played um ash and it's a
sin just like the most gorgeous man ever
and i said to him like i want you to
play this kind of like evil prince how
do you feel about snakes
and he was like i'm actually
more mortally afraid of snakes
i was like oh can you wear them on your
head though please
he did it and he was absolutely amazing
so yeah they it was just so fun to have
them back on on the scene be
like you know making some like fun
crazy visuals together it was really
yeah
you know when you appeared in or when
you starred and it's a sin last year i
mean critics loved it the audience loved
it i mean it really really made a splash
with everyone uh you know you said
playing that character richie
really influenced you and influenced
your your songwriting how so
well i feel like so when i'm so when i
was making
it's a sin
i
just like spending all that time
listening to 80's music and every day on
set we play in the trailer and we you
know the soundtrack to the show is so
good as well and it just really i just
really i've loved that period of music
always but really like reintroduced me
to it and
i think that definitely had an impact
because right after i finished filming i
went i went i was like okay i've got to
finish this album and then the pandemic
happened and
like everything changed and
but um that was like the music i went
back to you know because i just i just
love it it makes me feel good it's so
good and you're so good at it and can i
just say how obsessing with you and
kylie minnow
you guys are you sound wonderful
together i love watching you two
together um what's it like working with
her
just dream come true just like the best
feeling ever honestly she's just
wonderful i i have so much
admiration and respect
for her and yeah i'm just so happy to
like now you know have to work with her
so this is amazing she's such a pro as
well so
yeah you can't have a bad day you can't
have a bad day nothing bad
and kylie's around
i'm i mean i feel that way and maybe
that's why i love watching you two
together so much it's just like such a
good feeling um you both performed on
bbc's new year's eve show which some
viewers dubbed too sexy which in my
opinion is like a compliment
but how did you react to hearing that
oh it sucks occurs being this sexy it's
hot it's tough
i mean
obviously i feel like there's a job well
done if i've
had some complaints but
i know i was just kind of yeah it's
amazing um you know but yeah i you yeah
people are so funny huh you're like
that's what you're gonna write in about
okay
this is it it's like okay you really
took the time to make a complaint
i guess like fair enough
yeah you know when you're working with
someone who is so iconic as kylie
minogue what have you learned the most
from her is there a piece of advice that
she's given you that that you really
connected with
i think
well one of the things i love most about
kylie is like she's
she she's like so
i think like as a fan of hers like you
you feel like she doesn't judge you do
you know what i mean like she would
understand she's got an authenticity to
her because she's kind of
warm and kind and
as well as being like incredibly sexy
and just like
a goddess like she's also a human being
i think you know i mean like you really
get that from her
and like just being able to spend a bit
of time with her and hearing her like
how passionate she is about making music
still and how much she loves it and and
and how like um you know like she still
gets nervous and stuff like that that's
just it's like very encouraging i think
for me to to hear because you just think
oh wow you know you're such an icon
you're so real do you know what i mean
like she's she's the best i love her
yeah i love that authentic i think
that's such a good word to describe but
that's awesome being real um you know
years and years originally started as a
trio
and this is the first time that you're
stepping out and you're creating music
as a solo artist what was that
experience like
yeah i mean
i'll be honest it's kind of been on the
cards for like a while so yeah it was
like we
were a band but like we weren't really a
band anymore if that makes sense and we
kind of like once we wrapped up the
second album we finished touring it was
like we kind of needed to have this
conversation but we sort of like let it
go on for a while
and i think it was hanging over all of
our heads a bit so once we had kind of
been honest with each other and it would
all happen like honestly as as as like
amicably and like peacefully as it as it
could have um because we like do like i
think still love and you know like we
respect other and all that stuff so that
was good but and like it was kind of
like a relief but then and like a weight
off our shoulders and for me as well
like to kind of just go okay well this
is how i'm gonna do things moving
forward and feel like oh i've got a lot
of you know feel like i have freed you
know like a bit more freedom now i
suppose like um not that i wasn't free
before but you know i mean it's just a
feeling but um
like a big change though you know
because we've been together for like
nearly ten years so
it's um it's it was a bit strange but
mike mikey i saw mikey recently and he
played with us recently and he's going
to be on tour with us so you know we're
still we're still a family
yeah then it must make you feel so good
that the songs that you have released
from the new album
people are loving
[Laughter]
exactly so yeah it's like it's it's
really good it's like oh thank god
yeah that's awesome so then just
wrapping things up you know when it
comes to this new album what's the
journey that you hope listeners go on
when they listen from like top to bottom
oh well when i was making it i really
just wanted it was my escape you know i
mean it was just like
i wanted to just dance around when i was
in the studio i wanted to feel
like strong when i was singing whatever
it was about like i just wanted to
really like let myself go and have a
good time and that's honestly
that is the main thing i want people to
get when they listen to it is just have
a good time and you know like get taken
somewhere to get taken away somewhere
for a little bit
i feel like people are craving that now
more than ever even like i feel like we
wanted that like two years ago and then
people were saying that last year and
even now people like we need it more
than ever no we still need it
i know
um are you gonna do any more acting is
that something that you want to do
because you're so good
oh thank you i i would love to for sure
i am
i would love to i just have to be like i
guess the right thing and i don't know i
don't know what it's going to be but um
something at some point yeah